just to remind you the kind of way that
the easy quick and dirty way a lot of
people don't approve this is with the
triangle okay but can you remember what
the problem was with the triangle yeah
that's right it restricts you a lot when
you form this triangle and I think it's
the opposite so this is the arm the
right angle triangle that you form it
you can try and see the ratios from
there obviously because right angle this
means theta must be acute right so
between not m19 exclusive it doesn't
even include the batteries right but we
want to be able to use these T results
all the time and you bet you can right
so that's why this is this previous
focus okay now i showed you earlier one
proof with identities till not going to
redo that one because you can go watch
the video that's why i take videos okay
but I have another proof and I think
it's a bit faster okay so that's why I
called it ultimate proof for that ok so
i guess this is I guess it's an
alternative alternative proof because uh
because if the puzzle sound so i reckon
mrs. probably is the fastest other ones
that are given you so where do we start
including try one well maybe it's about
the same as the triangle one but the
triangle one is part dodgy so it's not
that good an option so where do we begin
what's the what is the tea interiors off
what is there for ten theory good okay
now obviously always because we're
talking about tans right the first place
you go is just 10 feet up not fit onto
okay so you can just use a straight
substitution of the double angle formula
here so you're going to get to 10th in
or two on and so on but since we know
what tempted onto is we're just defining
it as T the end up here quite quickly
okay so no props right now think in my
earlier proof i started with a sign well
actually i remember this time I'm gonna
start with cosine okay
now again just like with town i'm going
to use the double angle formula ok
what's the double angle formula because
if i send us a cause Cheers what's that
equal to good now this is right there
are several but they all come back to
the same one okay so okay so the basic
one the basic one is this cos square
minus sine squared okay frog which you
can convert that into two different
other ones you can convert it into one
which is all sides so you go 1-2 sine
squared X right so that's all sides or
you can go the other way and you can
vote into all cousins so you get this
yes is that ring bells okay now just
looking at what I'm trying to prove
right I'm trying to show that close
theater is going to be 1 minus t spend
on 1 plus T spread so all in terms of
tans okay now how are these one two
three options which do you think would
be best ya think I think we can kind of
rule out the middle one right why would
the middle one not be that useful for us
because in terms of two different
functions right so you get have to
substitute two different means that's a
bit awkward right so then your option is
well which of these would be more useful
right now remember since we're trying to
get things in terms of tans right hands
which of these would be easier to turn
to something in terms of tent top or the
bottom one this is interesting okay I
want you to I won't make you put your
hand up but I want you to write the top
your page right now which one you think
the sign one or the clubs on commit and
I think about it right um you write
write down first I want you to make a
decision okay because this is kind of
important even though i'm going to show
you this new you can memorize it's not
that high so that long um you need to be
able to have this skill right when you
have you know whatever identity you know
left-hand side equals right hand side
and you have to make some decisions
about what identity should i use which
would get me from one
to the fastest okay so which one is it
yeah let me written one down have you
already went down you're an option yeah
okay I'm gonna go from the bottom okay
now yep yes or ok so let me try and
justify it first I'll write it down now
because what I've got here is Theta
naught to X right that's what turns this
into a feed on to yes oh k minus 1 now
remember my destination is all in terms
of tears okay and the is identity that I
thinking of which involved tans and
cosines right especially when it's
squared is I'm going to use a sec square
remember that one okay so in order to
use sex square I'm going to turn this
upside down which is a little awkward
reciprocal of a reciprocal okay but sick
squared whatever I know what that's
equal to in terms of tears if you go
back to the Pythagorean identity flips
plus okay if you divide the whole lot by
cos squared okay what do you get to buy
that through you get tan squared divided
that through you get one and on the
right-hand side that's where that
control I've always confused the sex
squared one this one is easy to remember
but this way you use like Harper's often
so if you have trouble memory that's
that's how I do it I think no thats x
squared is what i have in the bottom
here so that's 2 on 1 plus 10 squared
okay you probably could do something
this time I just think it's less direct
okay so now that I've got this tan feed
on two and then I'll just substitute it
for a team and this minus one over here
I can bring on top of the fraction
combine these two okay so i'm going to
get a 1 plus T squared on the top and
you can see that's how I arrived here
that's cause okay so this is what i mean
i think i'm pretty sure this proof is
quicker than the previous identity proof
that i gave you okay that's mostly it
really you're like ah but i gotta prove
that the sign one it'll take at least as
long right no it does it because I've
got a good tan and I've got close will
sign right sign on cause that's that's
10 right so therefore sign is 10 times
cause I know what both of those are okay
so that's two T on 1 minus t squared
times that and you just get the
cancelling ok so to tea on 1 plus T
Square and you're finished see I mean I
think probably the hardest things to
remember in this proof our number one
get get that form right number to
remember that you can use this second
squared identity those are the hardest
part that's not that hard and the falls
are quite quickly okay